median house Sparks has been
entertaining his fans with his
appearances in Queer as Folk Spider-Man
2 Dude where's my car and of course Talk
Soup and now he's entertaining his fans
on stage with nerd Halen and he's here
to talk all about it welcome to the show
hi thanks it's nice to be back it's good
to see you I'm glad everybody's here
yeah yeah
um and you left out Lab Rats because all
those kids are right now entering the
age of the Disney XD fans are old enough
to go to a casino now is that a trip
yeah for your fans see your fans grow
through through the years yeah I mean
you know and I have my career is so like
splotchy it's you know it comes from
different quarters so I never know if
somebody goes I love your show it's nice
to know that I have to guess which one
it could be anyone I'm a huge fan I'm
gonna go uh Talk Soup and I love the 80s
Zone yes yeah yeah on point yeah yeah
and there's and I got zoltaned by
members of the crew today which is
lovely got it so yeah so I'm building my
own little sub Cults on on all fronts
that's good you want to have a huge fan
base which you do but let's break this
down tomorrow night yeah nerd Halen at
the end M Resort at the Pavilion
fantastic setup what is nerd Halen what
are you guys doing so uh we are a Van
Halen tribute band and we do the songs
as close as possible to the record as we
can because I feel like that's the root
thing of a tribute band you must sound
as much like the record as possible
because that's what the fans want that's
what they deserve and then if you do if
you nail it then you can joke around in
between the songs and be funny the rest
of the time and also I think it's I
always think it's a little bit sad when
people try to recreate the the sexy cool
look of a band when they do it so we
kind of let the audience Off The Hook by
just being goofy and have a great time
while they're watching the show and then
when they hear the songs they're like
yeah these guys care we're fans
ourselves you know you're not making fun
of them music it's a true trivia yeah we
are we're and and all four of us come
from different angles on the band so we
all have different favorite songs we all
have different favorite eras and that's
it's great because we don't we're not
all just locked on to six songs or five
hits or whatever and so we genuinely
love these songs and then what we do is
we fall in love with the songs the other
band members like that you figure out
after like why that hit them why that
was so much fun and then the best thing
about this is the audiences
you know they just get to have a good
time like the the world is sadly short
of Joy these days and so anything that
can bring that kind of Happiness to a
group of people is a plus in my book and
it's so great to just watch people even
the people who are like Eddie Van Halen
fans who sit there with their arms
crossed like Gene Simmons dirt you know
mid bass solo just like I'll see and
then you get them yeah right it takes
about two seconds and they're like I
love these guys because they love what I
love well do you have are you are you
van Hagar are you Van Halen we do both
okay we're one of your personal
preference oh my my person I'm a big
David Lee Roth fan I love him I love his
energy I love his ego yes I do the jump
splits of course I take some skills oh
yeah go to nerdhaling.com you can see
like shots of it and I will be doing it
tomorrow night no warm-up by the way I'm
just that challenge yeah absolutely
there's something I want to touch on
because with Demar Hamlin and that's
scary situation yes okay and then uh CPR
brings them back to life you know CPR
right yes I do I've done CPR three time
on three complete strangers yeah yeah
you save three lives by doing sleep
that's right yeah the second one was not
a complete stranger it was a guy at my
gym an older man who I knew this guy Don
who was there and uh but everybody else
complete strangers and you're at an
airport or something someone goes yeah
LAX yeah there was the last one was this
uh old Guatemalan man bless his heart
grandfather had just seen his family was
flying home and I'm in line I'm so late
for like I'm flying to a gig and I'm
like I'm gonna miss my flight blah blah
and they put me off in this little like
Disney line oh you know where you're
like I'm gonna make it and then you're
like no you're not and I'm like okay I'm
just done so and I hear you know that
noise when somebody stumbles and Falls
that's not supposed to stumble and fall
an older person that noise everybody oh
that noise yeah so I hear that and I
turn around and somebody's yelling he's
having a heart attack does anybody know
CPR and I wait for what seems like nine
minutes in my head but it was about four
seconds and I went nobody was doing
anything and I was like I guess that's
me okay all right here we go and so yeah
yeah it took me about seven minutes they
took him away alive I I got his pulse I
lost it twice it was that it was a it
was work it was a lot and um and but he
he survived and that was a you know so
learn CPR so I don't have to do this I
don't have to do this I want to watch
you be a hero you're saving lives Hal
Sparks thank you so much absolutely
exciting story yeah and check out nerd
Halen tomorrow night it's the mashup of
Van Halen